so when we wanted to premiere season
three I like to do it with personal
relationships and friends and I asked
Justin if he would come on the show and
what was your response
I was with him when he got the um ask
and he's like oh Drew wants me to go on
her show and I said oh you have to do it
and
yeah I was so excited I was so excited
because I knew there's so much love
between the two of you and
um so much yes fun and like a wild I
always say you guys were like in the
tornado together yes right yeah yeah
it's like it's the time in your life
where you're just like I want to like
feel I want to do everything I want to
you know just like be a part of the
adventure in like a wild way which is so
much fun
um and he just he just loves you so much